hey I'm Quincy with free code camp org
and I'm hanging out here with my son
Quentin as we do most days I work from
home and I like to spend a lot of time
with him I also like to keep my
JavaScript in my CSS skills sharp and
sometimes they don't have the
availability of my hands I can't look at
the screen so we created an Amazon skill
which you can use if you have an Amazon
Alexa unit and you can just say Alexa
start the free quiz two one the CSS
property text transform is mainly used
for one transformation of
family to increase or decrease font size
three alternation of text letter-case
for changing on color three that answer
is correct your scores one question
which is not Alexa and would you like to
know so the way that quiz works is it
will ask you ten questions and it just
tallies up however winning you get right
and did you score at the end and each
time it gives you random questions we
have a growing Bank of questions
another cool thing you can do if you
have a minute is you can just say Alexa
play the free code camp podcast
episode of the free code pan podcast and
you can listen to the free code camp
podcast which comes out every Monday and
it's me Quincy interviewing somebody
exciting from the developer community
Alexa stop another thing you can do if
you have an iPhone is you can just press
down the button and use Siri to listen
to the freakin podcast there to play the
free code camp podcast so it's playing
an episode I was listening to previously
just starts it wherever it was and I can
pause it and there's another important
command that I want to all you to try
out subscribe to the free code camp
podcast yes so if you do that then every
Monday when a new episode comes out and
you're on your way to work you'll get
you open up the Apple podcast app and
you can immediately listen to the free
code camp podcast so those are a lot of
things we're doing to make it easy for
busy parents like myself to be able to
learn on the go and I hope you enjoy
them
Cheers